a very good morning and welcome to Sky
News breakfast it's good to have you
with us Sky News has spoken to a British
man who's recently returned from the
front line in eastern Ukraine after
deciding to go there and fight while he
was lying on the sofa watching Netflix
at home
Douglas who's 26 fixes tractors for a
living and had no military background
but he quit his job and volunteered to
join the war on National correspondent
Tom Parmenter has his story
as a mother it was very very tough
a nightmare
he wanted to go and help and I totally
got all that
but
I didn't like this feeling
and I didn't expect it to still be so
Raw
feeling so low after it
they thought their boy might not return
home from the front line in Ukraine
but Douglas did make it back to the
family farm in Southwest Scotland
the helicopters are the worse
you'll hear though
by this point you're crawled out the
wall going not today please not today
he had no military training but still
decided he had to go I was sat here
actually drinking a beer watching
Netflix uh made my decision
packed up the stuff and
left my job enough on it
you're like I'm young enough I can
contribute to a better world
he was known as soap a video game
character who was now in the reality of
trench warfare they shut the hell out of
us you're sending a hole in the ground
which is
the wrong hat there's no coming out of
it we've seen it
down for a few of our guys
I think we get we get to come home
but they don't
they don't
the sadness is Blended with the
exhilaration of liberating Villages that
have been occupied by Russians you know
there's like people lined up in the
streets with table tops selling
vegetables there's people starting to
build houses
you get to actually see that it just
made everything
worthwhile you tell me that you were
considering whether you go back I hang
off
packed and unpacked that bag
several different times
they'll go back to the front they'll do
something else do it
yeah so it's it's and then the effect on
the family and friends
it's a it's quite a dilemma
I think it would be a suicide mission if
he did go back to Ukraine I really do
mentally and physically for them he's
been you know he's been shot at nearly
killed concussion
um the list was on I mean we're lucky
we've got Douglas Park but in Ukraine
there's a lot of people that won't be
coming back
this war which became his war is far
from over
Tom Parmenter Sky News
well let's just have a look at this
morning's other main developments on the
war in Ukraine and breaking news this
morning the president of Belarus
Alexander lukashenko is to visit China
next week last September Chinese
president Xi Jinping announced a
strategic partnership with their
Belarusian leader who is of course a
staunch Ally of Russia's Vladimir Putin
and yesterday Beijing called for a
comprehensive ceasefire between Russia
and Ukraine and a gradual de-escalation
in Bulgaria thousands of demonstrators
took to the streets of Sofia to express
their support for Ukraine they were
joined by some of the 50 000 Ukrainian
refugees who found shelter in Bulgaria
in the last year
meanwhile it's been announced that
around 3 000 tickets for this year's
Eurovision song contest will be
allocated to ukrainians now living in
the UK it will of course be hosted in
Liverpool this may and the UK government
has also announced 10 million pounds
worth of funding for the event
now the former leader of the dup has
accused the government of politicizing
the monarchy after Sky News revealed
that King Charles was being lined up to
play a key ceremonial role in the final
stages of negotiations with the EU over
Northern Ireland our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates has this exclusive
report
King Charles in Northern Ireland just
days after taking the throne he says
this nation is a personal priority for
him just as it was for his mother
with a brexit deal on Northern Ireland
imminent Sky News can reveal that number
10 had put in motion a meeting between
the king and the president of the
European commission Ursula vondeline
the meeting now canceled would have
happened at Windsor Castle today the New
Deal was expected to be called The
Windsor agreement labor say it would
have jeopardized the political
neutrality of the monarchy it seems that
there is panic within number 10 and they
are reaching for all sorts of quite
absurd policies and levers to try and
pull now I do not know how a thought of
involving the king can pass somebody's
mind and reach it to their mouth before
they realize that this is a very very
unwise policy to choose because it has
constitutional implications it certainly
would be very highly insensitive to the
politics of Northern Ireland and it
certainly is nothing we should ever be
involving his majesty in
the support of the dup for any new
brexit deal important for Rishi sunak
but the Sky News Revelation prompting a
backlash from the very unionists he
needs to win over former dup leader
Nigel Dodds said to plan for
politicizing the monarchy in this way is
very serious and reinforces the
questions about number 10's political
judgment over the protocol
we are days maybe just hours away from a
new brexit deal being agreed to try and
sort out issues in Northern Ireland and
positive noises on Friday night after a
call between Rishi sunak and the head
negotiator for the EU Ursula Vander lion
but it will be controversial which is
why you'd expect Rishi sunak and the
king and both sets of advisors to be so
cautious about involving the monarchy
had a meeting gone ahead it would have
been enormously controversial if it had
gone ahead in this context I think it
would have been extremely significant I
think it would have been one of the most
profound uh events and consequences for
the crown of Charles III's Reign because
he would have been putting himself right
into the middle of a highly contentious
political debate
a huge job ahead for number 10 this
Revelation has not made a deal any
easier to sell Rishi sunak trying to
make peace with Europe but can't escape
the Menace from his back benches samcoat
Sky News Westminster
foreign to discuss this further is our
political correspondent Rob Powell who
joins me now from Westminster um hi
again Rob Sam was just saying there how
much do you think this contentious
Revelation that King Charles may have
been involved is going to overshadow
what is said to be a rather defining
moment for Rishi sunak well it was
angering the very people that Rishi
sunak needs to keep on board if he's to
get this brexit deal done without there
being An Almighty Civil War inside the
conservative party you saw the reaction
of the dup uh Lord Dodds there and Sam's
piece clearly uh unionists For Whom the
monarchy is very important also Tory MPS
though Jacob Reese Moga brexiteer has
told Sky News overnight that this plan
would border on a constitutional
impropriety we already know that Boris
Johnson has been sounding off against
the plans and not necessarily
guaranteeing that he would vote for them
so I think it shows a degree of
political naivety that this was even
suggested although number 10 will of
course say that any meeting between the
king and nurse live on the line would
have been separate to the actual brexit
process the Optics the visuals though
clearly would have inserted the king
into this process and we are at a moment
where we look to be edging towards a
state where the bre where a brexit
agreement could be done with the
European Union there was a call between
Michigan
last night that was said to have yielded
good progress and been positive
conservative MPS have been put on
standby as well for a possible vote as
soon as Monday but not a helpful
development at a pretty crucial point
for the prime minister
okay Rob for now thanks very much speak
to you again in the next hour
now people have described their whole
house shaking after a small earthquake
in South Wales overnight the European
Mediterranean seismological Center said
a 3.8 magnitude earthquake was recorded
eight miles north of the Ronda Valley in
South Wales just before midnight and the
British Geological Survey the UK's main
provider of this sort of data has not
yet issued any information however we
are hearing from some of you people have
taken to Twitter sharing their
experiences one person tweeting thought
someone was breaking into my house no
just an earthquake in South Wales
another said we can confirm the walls of
our house shook in earthquake just after
midnight in South Wales felt like a car
had driven into the house
and another tweeted uh we've had many
earthquake Tremors before in Wales but
that Tremor shook my house to the core
in Eber Vale and did you experience the
earthquake well we would love to hear
from you if you felt it you can get in
touch with us you can go to the your
report tab on the Sky News Mobile app or
you can tweet me directly at Sally
Lockwood and we do have a few more of
you who've got in touch in the last hour
Matt oh she from gwent has told us that
his whole house shook for about five
seconds and others said it felt like
their property had been hit by a car I'm
in rimney and felt the house Shake
looked online to see if anyone else did
and it was an earthquake in South Wales
I think any I need a change of trousers
that tweet was from Chris otley thanks
Chris for that
um and Helen uh casewell added our whole
house shook in rasau ebbeil and woke my
husband up really frightened us and
lastly I've we've also heard from Jack
Hill also in gwent who said I thought
some idiot had driven into my front door
the way my room shook no Jack turns out
it was an earthquake in South Wales we'd
love to hear from you uh if you were
also affected you can get in touch with
us directly at Sky News or you can tweet
me directly at Sally Lockwood and no
doubt I'll also hear from some of you
about my appalling pronunciations on
Welsh names so apologies if I've made
any mistakes there but we've loved
hearing from you do get in touch
also making the news this morning a
fifth person has now been arrested in
connection with the shooting of a police
officer in Northern Ireland detective
Chief Inspector John Caldwell was shot
multiple times in Omar on Wednesday
night in front of his young son and he
remains critically ill a 43 year old man
has been arrested in the Stewartstown
area under the terrorism act and four
other men aged between 22 and 47 have
also been arrested
a couple has made history by holding the
first female same-sex wedding in the
British Antarctic territory witnessed by
a colony of penguins Sarah and June
seidner Cayman tied the knot on
Valentine's Day congratulations to them
that is a rather original one
to the US now where producers of the
movie rust have agreed to pay a 100 000
fine for safety breaches following a
fatal shooting of cinematographer Helena
Hutchins meanwhile a video has emerged
of Alec Baldwin practicing firing a gun
on the film set just a week before the
incident well joining me now to discuss
this further is our correspondent Sadia
Chaudhary hi to you Sadia this video
very interesting
um and it's emerging of course around
the same time not only are there quite
big legal proceedings in place but also
a lot of scrutinies emerged about the
sort of training that Alec Baldwin had
for firing this gun yeah lots of
questions about what happened on the set
and this video let's have a look at it
straight away this video obtained uh by
our colleagues at NBC News it shows Alec
boarding coming out of a church is
firing a gun this is during rehearsals
and it's been obtained through a freedom
of information request and it shows him
during rehearsals firing that gun we
don't know much more about the details
but it was in a similar incident during
a similar rehearsal that in 2021 a live
round from one of these prop guns was
discharged killing Helena Hutchins and
she was a 42 year old cinematographer
killed on the set during the making of
This film now the latest in this is that
the film's producers have agreed to pay
a hundred thousand dollar fine that's
being paid to the occupational health
and safety Bureau in New Mexico it's
been reduced it's taken almost a year of
them negotiating reducing it down by
about 30 000 pounds now the film's
producers say that their intention has
always been to resume production because
they want to complete the film they say
that's the best way to honor Helena
Hutchins uh and and her her role in the
film and it is one of several legal
proceedings we know of course that Alec
Baldwin is going through criminal
charges facing two charges of
involuntary manslaughter in a case in
the U.S as well as facing a civil
lawsuit from the family of Helena
Hutchins Alec Borden of course denies
those criminal charges his lawyers say
that this case is a farce and a
miscarriage of Justice okay Sadia thanks
very much for the update thank you
now millions of Nigerians will head to
the polls this morning in the most
competitive and unpredictable elections
yet it's Africa's largest Democratic
exercise but the continents most
populous nation and largest economy is
at a critical Junction with record
unemployment worsening insecurity and a
crippling cash crisis well our Africa
correspondent user Abigail joins me now
live from Lagos good to see you yusra
thanks so much for joining us certainly
Nigeria is facing a number of challenges
and it is hope that this election could
prove something of a turning point
yeah I mean of the 93.4 million
Nigerians who've signed up to vote more
than 7 million of them are here Lagos is
the state with the most signups in the
country it's also home to Africa's most
popular city and the economic capital of
the country here is where you can really
feel the pinch of the economy and the
cash shortage we've spent time with
people over the last few days and here
is what we found out
foreign
in Nigeria
and all around Lagos promising Smiles
are asking to be chosen
a new Administration is forming that
will govern the country for the next
four years
but Africa's largest population is
preoccupied with personal matters here
on a single Road in the economic capital
bustling banks are the bad kind of busy
we're on one of the main streets in
Lagos and all along this road are crowds
of people standing outside of banks
waiting to get their hands on some cash
people are angry
unable to access their own funds to buy
Basic Essentials
the morning I was here they said we
answered before eight o'clock from eight
o'clock not until now you never see
anything to collect I'm not going to go
to anybody I'm not going to vote for
anybody at all I'm putting to my God and
and hungry man is an angry man
the cash shortage comes after currency
redesign policy was introduced by
incumbent president muhammadu buhari
said to combat illicit cash flows and
vote buying Central Bank is trying to
control the money and circulation
because they feel they have too much
cash outside of the banking system you
don't have like what you have in the UK
where people would use cards to pay it's
cash based so people can't
get to the offices people can't
pay for things in the market
and so the hustle of everyday life has
become even harder the despair is
driving a rift between the people and
their potential new leadership we have
governments we have politicians but all
most of them they're like how should I
put they're just tips they don't want to
spend money they don't they don't want
to spend money on that you they just
want to spend money only on them so
but the hope is that this discontent has
pushed Nigerians to the polls rather
than away from them all Nigerians to
actually vote is is necessary civic duty
not for yourself but for your
generations to come
more than 93 million people have
registered to vote
and those that cast their ballot to
filling their civic duty are banking on
Nigeria's new rulers to fulfill theirs
and bring about some much needed change
and you sir give us a picture
of the main contenders in this race it
sounds like there could be a historic
runoff
yeah I mean this is the tightest race in
Nigeria's political history since
democracy was introduced in 1999. you've
got two main Front Runners you've got
the ruling parties Bola Ahmad tanubu is
the former governor of Lagos you've got
the main oppositions parties at atiku
Abu Bakr who is a former vice president
his party the people democratics party
has ruled the country since 1999 except
in the last eight years of President
muhammadu buhari's Administration these
are the two main Front Runners but there
is a wild card in the race you've got
the lesser-known labor parties Peter Obi
he's more than a decade younger than his
two opponents he's 61 years old he's a
former Banker he's also the former
governor of anambra state and he is
galvanizing young people here now he may
be unlikely to Garner the state majority
vote needed to win but what he might do
is split the popular vote enough to lead
to a runoff which would be as you said
the first in the country's history
okay used to it thanks very much indeed
back to the war in Ukraine now and a
year on no end insight to the conflict
to discuss this further I'm joined by
former special advisor to the Commanding
General of the U.S Army in Europe Mark
Voyager a very good morning to you thank
you very much uh indeed for joining us
now you are in uh Sofia in Bulgaria and
of course there's been large protests
there in support of Ukraine what's the
feeling in Bulgaria
good morning Sally and uh thank you for
having me
um well the feeling is that uh you know
for the last year Russia has been uh
waging this unjust brutal atrocious war
against effectively a neighbor of
Bulgaria in the region uh so many there
um here rather protested and joined in
this protest but of course the society
is divided unfortunately because the
Russian propaganda is quite active um
across Europe and in particularly in
Bulgaria so you know Russian trolls you
know Russian messages are being pushed
through
um you know uh Shady Internet Resources
so unfortunately there are also many who
are adulthood who think they support uh
Putin and Russia's goals but but what we
saw yesterday was really impressive on
on the part of those who understand that
the future of Ukraine is in Europe and
the Ukraine really defends uh Europe's
and and the Western democracy and it
belongs to Europe it's um it's our best
a hope for holding any future Russian
advances toward uh additional NATO
members or EU members yes we've seen
we're looking at some extraordinary
images from Sophia
um yesterday you know of course
Bulgaria's taking in around 50 000
Ukrainian refugees
um little surprises so much support
there for ukrainians but it's just
interest me interested me that you've
talked about the fact that there is a
lot of Russian propaganda which is also
getting through uh to people in other
parts of Europe outside of Russia and it
is having an impact how much does that
concern you about the wider security
issues in Europe
uh it's fundamental to the security of
Europe and becomes information Warfare
is Central to what we call a Russian
hybrid Warfare it is uh the pillar of
hybrid Warfare really and even when uh
military power fails in the battlefield
which is uh what's happening now in
Ukraine you know the Russians are not
winning as we can see still they're able
to project those messages
um of um of with a certain degree of
confidence I mean you saw Putin's speech
I mean he spoke and acted as if he's a
winner and is it Russia will win in the
long run and unfortunately many
um I would say across Europe maybe
buying some of those messages and
definitely many in the in the so-called
Global cells among those countries for
example that voted
to opted to remain neutral during the
vote in the EU and they definitely
unfortunately see this conflict is
framed within this new uh colonialist
framework
and so the Western diplomacy must work
actively and not only you know to to
create a united front against Russian
propaganda within the west west as a
whole but also uh among countries of uh
outside of our region in the global
South
and of course we've seen China taking a
much more active role in recent weeks
when it comes to Ukraine uh Chinese uh
the Chinese foreign minister visiting
Moscow this week in breaking news this
morning that the leader of Belarus will
be visiting China later this month as
well do you believe the U.S intelligence
that we could soon see China providing
lethal weapons to Ukraine
and the in our own intelligence uh has
been quite good at pinpointing uh such
uh you know future developments you know
the warnings before the war started uh
so uh you know I would actually trust
them
um and I would just say that you know
the proposed plan uh by China is is a
really a double faced effort to try to
portray China as a peacemaker on a
global scale while at the same time uh
they are effectively negotiating with
Russia as uh also journalistic
investigations uh showed the German
speaker and
um and then other resources
um show that they're preparing to
potentially sign a deal uh contract
rather with Russia to supply drones so
on the one hand you know over
um kind of projections of this uh you
know peaceful Peacemaker image on the
other hand uh potentially attempts to
support Russia's War II just because
China doesn't want a NATO to expand I
mean they spoke of this indivisible
security it's the Mantra that the
Russian foreign Ministry has been
pushing through you know non-nato
expansion and obviously keeping the West
um engaged in Ukraine is also uh also
placed
um in China's favor so you know I would
I would think this is uh what might may
happen if the war continues the channel
will will ultimately Supply some sort of
uh lethal Aid together with you know
with the electronic components and
components and financial instruments
that they're already providing uh to
facilitate Russia's wherever yeah as you
say U.S intelligence has been largely
extremely accurate in terms of
predicting uh the developments of this
war
if indeed China does provide lethal Aid
to Ukraine to Russia what difference
would that make and how concerning is
that well in the first place that would
mean China is becoming a party to this
uh war with all the consequences of this
I mean there will be really heavy
sanctions uh imposing them by the U.S
but also I would think by the European
Union and by Europe as a whole in China
doesn't really want to lose its European
markets uh you know it may be in a state
of Confrontation or at least tensions
with the us but you know the U.S the EU
markets are critically important for
China
um by this uh presidency would show that
he is really ideologically aligned with
Putin I mean we'll know that but now he
would have to take this next step and
really uh engage in China the same way
as as Iran I mean effectively a country
that supplies
um military lethal military aid to uh to
support the efforts of of an aggressor
in an unjust unprovoked brutal war of
extermination so that would deal a very
heavy blow to China's reputation across
the world at least in the eyes of the
West and of course with all the economic
and political consequences of that act
yeah we certainly find ourselves intense
geopolitical times Mark Voyager we
appreciate your time today thank you
welcome back now a war of words has
broken out over Ireland's plans to put
cancer warnings on all bottles of
alcohol Yes you heard that right the
European commission gave the Irish the
green light despite angry protests from
major wine producing countries
especially Italy where wine is a 12 and
a half billion pound industry from there
Stephen Murphy has a story
Italy is the world's number one wine
producer but it's more than just a
commodity here in Valpolicella wine is
intrinsically Heritage culture and a way
of life that's why Ireland's plan to
slap cancer warnings on their product
has caused such shock is it crazy is it
is a over over the limits it's over the
limits under Ireland's pioneering
legislation all alcohol products not
just wine will have labels like these
warning of liver disease and the link to
fatal cancers that we know that we have
the longevity
after the Japanese is the the area with
the the maximum of longevity why that
because of the cancer they come from the
eye called Kaman The Vines may be empty
at this time of the year but when you
come to a region like Val pelicella you
really get a sense of how crucial wine
is to the Italian economy it's an
industry worth around 14 billion Euro a
year and as employees around 1.3 million
people that's why Italy sees this Irish
plan as such a threat we can see the
these dangerous precedent at European
level and we think that these terrifying
warning labels are not the right way to
inform properly the consumer if these
will be followed but other member states
in particular they will be very damaging
for the for Italian wine industry and
exporters in particular the Italian
government is furious the country's
foreign minister described the Irish
plan as absurd and an attack on the
Mediterranean diet but the Irish are
determined to plow ahead and they have
the full support of Health campaigners
it is the first in the world and this is
why Ireland is a hero for the rest of
the world the science is very clear
alcohol causes cancer it is about
telling the truth and it's about the
people's right to know
Italians in Ireland say they're not
alone in their opposition I'm sure all
Europe Spain France eventually they're
not happy I just spoke with few why
importer and they told me they were all
in the same in the same boat on this the
major wine making countries say the
Irish plan is in breach of single Market
rules and it's currently being examined
by the World Trade Organization legal
action has been threatened and it seems
certain this European wine war will
continue to Bubble Stephen Murphy's Sky
News in Northern Italy
well with us this morning to review a
papers our broadcaster and journalist
Thomas Copeland and Anthropologist
Marianne ohota good to see you both
again thanks so much uh let's start with
the front page of the mirror Marianne if
I may there's been a lot of talk about
Therese Therese coffee I should say
Therese coffee and turnips tell us more
yeah uh yes let them eat turnips if you
can't find cucumbers or tomatoes in the
shop which you might not be able to find
or if you do they'll be pretty expensive
to raise coffee has said well we should
be eating more turnips we should cherish
what we do well in Britain which is
obviously eat uh growing turnips perhaps
not so much eating turnips comically
um alternative now had a bit of a run on
them so you might not find turnips in
the shops either
um
yeah they're all right I mean they're
not the same as eating a salad but
they're pretty good in on their own
terms I mean in my opinion it really is
the world's most boring vegetable
um but that said we do have an abundance
of them Thomas what do you make of the
fact that politicians are coming out
with lines like this do you think it's
it's a good thing or is it is it
slightly odd well I mean it's it's a
politically silly thing to do ever to
name one specific vegetable towards
which you recommend the public in the
context of a food shortage because
invariably you will then be bombarded on
social media with pictures of shelves
lacking that one particular food I think
it's a pretty rookie error and
somebody's senior is an environmental
secretary could have probably avoided
that one I mean listen it's one of these
stories where
um ultimately and actually Marianne's
made a really good point there it's less
about shortages and more about prices
and feeds into a much wider problem to
do with your cost of living and how much
how much cheaper junk food is and bad
food is uh you know as compared to the
kind of healthy food that we want to
encourage people to eat and so it's
probably and again you know in the
context of of brexit we're talking about
in the last storm we'll talk about in
The Next Star again these are the kind
of really difficult things that that
have been a consequence of brexit inside
the mirror and encourage people to read
it it goes through really nicely
actually all the different reasons for
some of these shortages to do with
higher costs we've had some bad weather
the costs of homegrown food has gone up
fuel us through the roof fertilizers
through the roof in terms of prices and
also brexit means that you know European
suppliers are less likely to to want to
send their food over over this side of
the English Channel and that means that
um it's you know either your face or
shortages or your face with much higher
prices and that's what consumers have to
put up with on top of all the other
increasing costs that they're facing at
the moment okay Thomas I am calling time
on turnips that's enough turnip chat for
the morning Marianne let's Jump Ahead to
page 19 of the times uh Laura who's in
my ear this morning has been saying
let's do the pig story no it's actually
a pug story moon pig though the card the
card maker moon pig has withdrawn cards
featuring pugs not pigs explain why yes
it's it's it's easy to misread that but
it is pugs you know the breed of dog
with the short flat faces and the bulgy
eyes some people think they're super
cute other people go that is exactly
human Folly translated into animal
cruelty because uh this particular breed
of uh dog is 54 times more likely to
have obstructed Airway disorders because
of the way that we've bred them really
short shorten the leg
um bulging eyes like those kind of
classic pug
um features and French Bulldog features
as well as well have got more and more
enhanced as we've bred them even since
Victorian times so Queen Victoria had
pugs but they were kind of longer
snouted longer limbed and therefore
healthier than what you would get now if
you bought a pedigree pug
so Peter the animal welfare charity have
been lobbying moon pig the card
manufacturers to say please stop putting
pugs on the fronts of greetings cards
because they're cute and people like
sending them because it's it's it's
enabling more animal cruelty it's making
this seem normal it's making it seem
desirable people want to own pugs
therefore people breed pugs and the pugs
are the ones who suffer so moon pig have
gone yeah all right fair enough we're
not going to design any more cards with
pugs on we're not going to Source any
more cards with pugs on uh all French
bulldogs
and um Peter say this is just the start
they're going to kind of approach other
card companies to follow suit and the
broad question is how we as a society
take our responsibilities for the pets
that we keep
um bearing in mind that Austria Germany
the Netherlands and Norway have all put
breeding restrictions on animals on dog
breeds that are considered to be
basically not able to live a quality of
life because of the way that we've bred
them okay Thomas it's probably a bit too
risky to try and introduce another story
with the time we've got left I'm afraid
so a quick thought from you on pugs well
I confess notwithstanding number of pogs
that I clearly see on the front of
greeting cards I've never found them
particularly cute and as a direct
consequence maybe that'll lose me some
of my many many online fans but I think
that you know as a consequence of the
way that they've been bred they have a
rather frustrating breathing pattern
that annoys me as they pass in the
street and that's definitely I don't
know why somebody's gonna attack Acme
online for that but you know that I I
kind of I broadly agree actually this is
really unhealthy for dogs and it does
nothing for humans and there's me a
great many ways in which you know a
cruelty is dealt onto animals and
there's justifiable in some ways reasons
for doing it because we need you know
meat and which to live and the way in
which we uh the way in which we our
society operates requires some of that
pugs is not one of them we can
definitely live with like breeding plugs
in this way Thomas Marianne great to see
you both see you again in the next hour
thanks so much uh for that and we'll
have all the news at the top of the hour
including all the latest on Ukraine stay
with us